so I'm waiting for the announcement of
the 2010 Nobel Prize in Chemistry the
physics prize yesterday was for graphene
almost chemistry so be interesting to
see what happens today whose names will
be revealed
will it Remo Mensa way from finding out
people talk about who might win the
prize but really very few people have
any idea because they don't know the
criteria that are chosen to judge these
things so usually well quite often it
comes as a surprise but then you think
gosh that was a good idea to reward that
so let's see if we'll be surprised today
[Music]
hello Lucy these are prizes for
reactions for making carbon-carbon bond
these inorganic molecules very famous
reactions heck reaction catalyzed by
delay diem and the Suzuki reaction which
is also quite similar right so it's a
very exciting day for organic chemists
three Nobel prizes in chemistry this
year all going through palladium
catalyzed cross coupling reactions well
it pioneered I guess it's a new reaction
of its kind that allows carbon-carbon
bond formation so imagine these two
carbons it's license to stick them
together which is an unnatural process
over the past few years the chemistry
prize has gone to really good pieces of
science but often it's been a bit of
science that isn't easily identifiable
with mainstream chemistry this prize
this year is really associated with
organic chemistry the things that
thousands perhaps millions of chemists
do every day making organic molecules so
I think it will really resonate oh yeah
we use it regularly I mean in fact we
we're doing one today in the lab so I
just show you what we're actually doing
so to explain it we make
your natural product and this this is a
structure of the natural product and
we're trying to make this bond between
these two carbon atoms here the price
has been won by three chemists two in
the United States one in Japan heck and
negishi
in United States and Suzuki in Japan and
all of them have a reaction named after
them so if we go backwards and split
this in half we get the two fragments
and these fragments what the Suzuki
reaction uses we use this veronik acid
and this what we call a vinyl bromide
and using a palladium catalyst of
palladium 0 it allows us to stitch these
two carbons together using the really
neat catalytic cycle when you find a
really good reaction you often get it
named after you the heck reaction Suzuki
reaction Negishi and all of these
reactions are designed for making
carbon-carbon bonds joining two
molecules each that contain carbon with
a single bond between two carbon atoms
you can imagine that this is really good
because it allows you to take small
building blocks and build up large
molecules like the molecules that you
find in natural products that are made
by strange organisms the common link
between all three Prize winners is their
reactions involve palladium palladium in
case you've forgotten is number 46 here
on the periodic table it's the element
immediately above platinum and the idea
is that you take some sorts of compound
for example in the case of the hick'ry
action it's a benzene ring and we've got
a halogen so this green one here is a
halogen it could be a bromine or an ID
or a chlorine and it has a bromine
attached to it and what they found was
that palladium is able to to snip this
bond off and then attach that bond to a
carbon though the palladium atom goes
between the carbon of the benzene ring
and the bromine so you can make a
carbon-carbon bond so here is the
heck reaction these aren't really quite
to scale but you get the idea a
carbon-carbon compound for example
ethane ethylene with just the double
bond between the two carbons comes in
and attaches to the Palladium this
making a carbon-carbon bond so this two
carbon unit bonds onto the benzene and
the bromine and the Palladium go away
into the solution and the two other
reactions the Suzuki and the neghishi
work on same principle Binstead a
bromine Negishi uses zinc and suzuki
uses boron or boron oxygen compound now
why is that important well all of the
pharmaceutical ingredients around the
world active pharmaceuticals they have
carbon-carbon bonds and there we've just
made one in a really simple fashion and
not only that but it's controlled we
know exactly where this bond is going to
be made
it's going to be made where that halogen
atom was previously and that for the
pharmaceutical industry really
revolutionized the way that they could
make molecules they could plan and put
anything wherever they wanted around
this ring the important thing is with a
small amount of palladium you can make a
lot of material well this is a play dium
catalyst which is used quite a lot
called palladium tetrakis or palladium
triphenylphosphine tetrakis so it's got
play diem with four tri-phenyl phosphine
groups around it and some nice materials
it's quite it's normally quite bright
yellow but let's have a look what this
is like oh this is okay it's not too bad
it's gone off a little bit so it's going
a little bit orange that means we need
to purify it before you use it right so
here we have the magic powder or one of
the magic powders this is palladium
acetate I'll just tip a little axe it's
quite difficult to see in there so
you'll see it's just a very benign
looking brown powder so quite sad and
amongst all this is that there would
have been a fourth contributor to this a
guy called John stili
tragically he was
killed he was that right in there at the
start he found that actually tin carbon
bonds could also be broken by palladium
the Nobel Prize can't be aborted
posthumously to people who have sadly
passed away so had he lived I think it
was a plane crash that tragically took
him away that he would have been the
fourth person it's important to remember
that we're gonna head off to my lab and
uh dr. Plaza Sharma is gonna show you a
Suzuki coupling they've been fortunate
enough to meet professional Negishi when
I was a student at Purdue University I
spent a year as an undergraduate there
and I interrupted him a couple of times
and he's a great guy and very
inspirational and put in my lab this is
dr. pleasure say hi fluffy probably
doing a Suzuki reaction today she does
quite a few of them
so what she'd do now she's taking their
apparatus and you see a big balloon on
top of it well that's full of filled
with argon which is an inert gas means
doesn't react with net much thing he's
filling up the syringe with some THF
which is dried we've got still here
which the THS in the bottom is sodium
wire and it distills up and it's nice
and dry in here she's injecting that
into the flask through this rubber
septum and that allows the solution to
go in without having contamination from
me I would say that Macpherson this is
all under like your argon still it's
great now it's gonna take a measured
volume of our substrate so now Bobby's
adding the reagents or the building
blocks in there so in that flash now
we've got some THF the two blocks that
were going to stick together and
nothing's gonna happen yet until we add
the catalyst so this is a play diem
catalyst I showed you earlier on and now
probably gonna add it it's quite a bit
there you can add it and all sudden now
the chemistry will start happening
sometimes you need to heat the reaction
but in this case we've done it several
times we're reproducing it it works very
well so yeah we're just going to leave
it for a couple hours now come back and
hopefully our building blocks would have
been stuck together and we've got our
compound that's a Suzuki reaction
you